[Applaudissements]
nous allons attaquer maintenant notre
partie télé réalité nous allons
accueillir si vous le voulez bien
maintenant notre invité qui va passer un
long moment avec nous en fin d'émission
par leur avec lui de la septième saison
des anges à partir de dimanche sur nrj12
merci d'accueillir matthieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui a reconnu la musique et les anges a
reconnu moi du coup ça va me tuer ça va
très bien mais bien voyez vous êtes ici
entre ennemis et
et j'ai eu rude
on peut être d'accord ou pas d'accord
mais il est ici avec des amis qui vont
débattre avec lui une nouvelle fois vous
êtes là vous n'avez rien d'être cachés
m'avait dit tout à l'heure je vous ai
dit ils vont taper fort mais rassure toi
je serai la portée des joueurs
[Applaudissements]
non je serai là pour les aider a tapé
fort
cette nouvelle saison s'annonce comment
en deux mots on en parlera enverra des
extraits tout à l'heure alors en deux
mois en plus moi je mens jamais donc
c'est ce qui me fait parfois c'est
dangereux pour moi la promo mais
honnêtement on n'a pas été au top sur
toutes les saisons la saison précédente
sept camions marché en audience la
saison 3 pour moi est un peu loupé
franchement celle-là s'annonce
extrêmement bien moi j'ai passé dix
jours là bas avec eux et honnêtement il
ya tout ce qu' on aime
comment vous êtes arrivé comment
écrivez-vous maison non honnêtement ma
gueule alors que vous avez passé du
joueur avec eux je voulais vérifier si
vous aviez toujours
[Applaudissements]
allez on y va
il ya maintenant un jingle qui démarre
car je me dois de les annoncer pour la
personne qui se donne du mal à les faire
voici le vus à l'étranger thé spécial
télé réalité je vous dis oui oui vous me
dites je ne sais pas de quoi il s'agit
et sakho je vous réponds c'est une
émission américaine qui est diffusée sur
mtv vous connaissez une terrible janvier
exactement qui connaît le pitch et 10
garçons les filles les garçons et des
filles qui ont été on a ça va être dur
pour moi mais bon asie de chacun en fait
scientifiquement il y en a un qui se
tiraient avec l'autre mais on le sait
surtout si on disait que
scientifiquement il ya trois les trois
filles du plateau correspondent à trois
hommes d'ailleurs deux filles pour un
garçon la nouvelle édition a commencé
c'était pareil sur les missions des
nudistes sur d8 ya toujours des toujours
c'était deux garçons pour une fille il
faut toujours qu'il y en ait deux quoi
mathieu qu'en pensez vous de ça je ne
connais pas du tout mais voilà on va
regarder un extrait pour vous être
agréable et vous nous direz ce que vous
en pensez après regardez